une démarche 100% dématérialisé depuis
ce mardi 30 juin les franciliens peuvent
proposer leurs projets leurs envies
autour de cinq thèmes une première porte
d'entrée assez classique avec des crocs
projets d'investissements pour des
villes ou des intercommunalités donc des
projets qui sont des projets
structurants à pourront aller jusqu'à
plusieurs millions d'euros mais vous
aurez aussi des microprojets et la
possibilité de déposer des micro projets
jusqu'à 10000 euros
et là n'importe quelle association
pourra ou n'importe quel individu mais
se structurant ensuite en association si
son projet est retenu pour à déposer sur
la plate forme pour ce lancement de
projets la région propose 100 millions
d'euros montant qui atteindra 500
millions d'ici 2024
les franciliens ont jusqu'au 14 août
pour déposer un dossier sur le site
dédié
on a souhaité que les projets
correspondent un certain nombre de
critères tout d'abord respecte l'intérêt
général respect qu une logique de
participation citoyenne respecte les
valeurs de la république et de la
laïcité
ce qui est extrêmement important
particulièrement aujourd'hui fassent
preuve de bienveillance et de respect
d'autrui
tiennent en compte la solidarité et
l'inclusion sociale l'équité
territoriale
les franciliens seront ensuite appelés à
voter du 18 septembre 2 octobre pour
s'exprimer et être âgé de plus de 15 ans
elle les premiers projets retenus seront
annoncés à l'occasion de la commission
permanente du mois d'octobre